I reject nation it's greg outta here now
I'm John we're gonna watch the extended
preview for Aquaman
today dressed like a fish I like it I
think this comes from NYCC mm-hmm that
stands for no you can't come because
you're in LA I don't know what new
footage just has to offer but heard this
was dropping pretty early this morning
let's check it out before we go into
that I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's joining us to becoming a
pie-chart eject over there we do weekly
Q&A as well as TV show reactions for
many a show that includes my hero
academia attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood as well as Gotham
Riverdale and supernatural there's my
other shows on there too but those are
the main ones recovering right now so to
come up with tragic to do
extended previously some similarities
[Music]
and now as a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day you're pregnant to having
a baby
disease
it's quality Nicole caiman in action I
always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the breach to oversee the house
take your rightful place
who's king it's a pretty cool Warner
Brothers logo actually built those out
of Sam that's that's what the line is
again
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert you do your best
thinking you're not thinking at all
right now hold still hey what are you
doing we need water you know closest
source you're the closest well she did
use five fingers okay okay it's cool
in this trident besides the power Odin
LaMarcus Wow
like the Gungan city to the hidden sea
the true heir
we do know that the mare kingdoms what
should we have written it down first I
memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what'd you say don't do
something giant is awakened
[Music]
oh this movie is gonna be awesome
yes yes
whoa
Wow shai her stunt doubles killing it
[Music]
oh dude
[Music]
are not going to win this
billions will die fish you help us
damn cool to see nicole kidman actually
kicking some ass yeah whoa
it's always had a key you need something
we are a monarchy
the chair is amazing
[Music]
[Music]
hey man that might have been my favorite
moment the costume oh gosh I was not
expecting such a different pace trailer
than the last one I thought we were
gonna get like a five minute version of
the other trailer just with a few more
scenes or something like that or you
know just a lot more faster images or
some kind of feature ed they've been
debating all night about what this was
supposed to be like what James ones been
teasing yeah yeah and then now that
they've released this I really
appreciated the the last Aquaman trailer
and you know I know there was a debate
about how the effects look and
everything and how's the tone really
gonna be struck hey the effects look
great here with in terms of the tone and
the pacing even though it's still in
trailer format you get a much better
sense of how this film will ultimately
feel they ultimately be pasted all the
different areas are exploring throughout
here sometimes I get a little sick of
that like stranger things like music
that sense for the edgy oh yeah I hear
it in so many things now and now is
hearing it hear it really worked because
I don't know I mean his trailer just
dropped for us so I don't know what
anyone else is saying about this trailer
watching this I found myself kind of
lost in the trailer like yeah this like
sense of wonder that was going on I
rarely feel that these days and we saw
venom last night which we have opinions
that was like magical to me that that
really felt magical it was cuz I mean at
least to me it seems like one of the few
frontiers that remains for movies to
really tackle is doing something that is
so heavily reliant on an underwater
world one thing that struck me about
this trailer is yeah you spend a lot of
time on land or above water and whatnot
but every element stood out in some way
like the designs the worlds that the
action the costume not that like that
insane I mean of course it wasn't just
one take but yeah fried that primarily
long tracking yeah they had was really
freaking cool dude and that wasn't even
one of the underwater moments they even
the better look at the underwater
water moments were awesome you know cuz
sometimes in the fast-paced imagery of
trailers like the last one it can leave
effects to be questionable but when you
have trailers like this where they let
the clip because this is an extended one
where they let the clips really take
their time a lot more you get to really
take in a lot of the visuals that you
have going on so the imagery of just
something like writing the sharks last
time it looked like cheesy cool to me
yeah and this time I was like that's
cool and I feel like doubling down on
the Aqua bro personality Aquaman kind of
helps those elements of the movie -
who's peed on it teeters on being maybe
a little silly but yeah kinda cool can
kind of be balanced out by just that
tone that comes from Arthur Curry's
portrayal in this movie you know I feel
like Amber Heard is gonna do a really
good job and I like the portrayal that
mop mop Jason mommy
Melissa mamoa as for Aquaman I'm still
not a hundred percent sold it's like
they have chemistry I don't know how
strong the chemistry is yet does that
see that they had I'm like you know
moments like that are really gonna
depend on their diet on my chemistry
weirdly that was like the only question
I really walked away from this is how
much am I gonna believe these two I mean
it's like I feel like they'll be fine
I just don't know I feel like this would
be better if that chemistry was really
if not I'm really poppin yet because I
mean amber heard everything I've seen
her and I think she has a lot of acting
chops and Jason Momoa has surprised me
with his acting chops and some other
things I've seen him in so it's like I
have no doubt that they both have it in
them and yeah now I'm just wondering
about the chemistry because that's the
only thing yeah that didn't like a
hundred percent click for me and yeah
not that it didn't click at all it's
just you know I would need to see a bit
more even though to imagine the hard
part and this was all the underwater
sequences I like the above-ground
sequences too because it's kind of got
this Indiana Jones flair about it's like
an archaeological exploration vibe even
with Jason Momoa is attitude that's even
more amplified by that there's also nice
to see where some of these actual lines
are taking place in the movie like the
wild lines approached
trailer that's badass oh it's in this
moment right here yeah looks badass like
amazing and that makes me wonder where
in the movie all that's going to occur
cuz most of that footage seems to be
from the same chunk of the movie so I
wonder how much that characters gonna
figure in overall it doesn't look like
he's the main threat of the story well
you do get a teaser Nereus self Lundgren
who's just having a comeback you tough
Lundgren here and Orem and I I don't
know if in that scene if they're talking
with each other like they're they're
aligning with one another or if they're
about to throw down is about to like
betray image done enough research in
that department of where the movies
taking that to find out Loki's gonna
kill Odin I mean it seems like that
black man is kind of being treated as
sort of an assassin for hire in this
that's how it feels
yeah there is little team that's the
vibe that I'm at least getting I don't
know how actual readers of this comic
book feel about that I mean who's not
that married to it I'm like alright yeah
I never read it actually Aquaman was
like hey I'll go Matt is like from grown
up and seeing him and like shows and
stuff and entourage yeah well you get to
see Nicole Kidman kick a little ass too
yeah man you gonna see Queen and Lana
kicking a lot of not a booty in this
film and that was neat because a lot of
times you know you get these like big
actors to play these supporting roles
and most of the time you're like did you
really need a powerhouse actress like
that and I still don't know if you need
a powerhouse actress like that but at
least they're definitely making use of
her enough to do yeah
bottom line it really got the vibe of
this trailer down pretty strong because
I love the exploration vibe I love the
Wonder vibe you know starting off at the
beginning of this trailer because the
other shows up at the you know Arthur
curry like as a kid and whereas lineage
is here I felt that sense of looking for
purpose even more I'm feeling you know
that's the thing is like before I saw
what they were going for
and this time around this extended video
made me go I am feeling what you're
going for and that's much more powerful
than just knowing what you're trying I
love this yeah this is amazing
took my breath away a couple times I was
that got me really excited I was
expecting that something might come out
this morning and then it did and I'm
like alright let's watch something fun
and then I got a lot more than I
actually anticipated from it I think
this is probably the most I've been
looking forward to this movie yeah it's
been a curiosity up until this point but
seeing this extended video yeah has
really made me anticipate well I can't
wait to see beyond the trailers
breakdown video of this what did you
think of this Aquaman trailer man that
was uh that was pretty sweet diggity I
like it yeah you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation and you can click that
notification Bell cuz you know what
youtubers say and check us on patreon TV
show reactions q and A's would love to
have some more men and a couple of women
become a big project today bye bye